in the heart of downtown nairobi there
is a rink
that rink is home to an unnamed ice
hockey team currently
we haven't found a name for the team but
we just call it the kenya hockey team
[Music]
my name is barnard azegure currently the
captain kenya is hockey league
i decided to play esoki simply because i
wanted to do something different
in kenya many people
we grew up playing different sports like
soccer athletics
i just want to do something that stands
out something unique
we have around 30 members in our team
we compete against ourselves
so whoever shows up we divide
the equal number of players
then we play against ourselves
[Music]
there's no money in ice hockey in kenya
unlike in europe where we have leagues
whereby
teams can buy players
pay them well here in kenya we're just
beginning
in the next
coming years ice hockey will be a big
spot
currently many people are joining and
we're hoping to get even more as time
goes
our future dream is for our kenyan team
to be featured in the winter olympics i
know we don't stand a chance
but
just
being there we might prove the world
wrong
once you achieve your dreams
there's a satisfaction
that
comes with it
it's just a good feeling
you're like okay we've made it finally
[Music]
you